pretty much the entire time I was on
Rick's podcast he was telling me to get
the mic closer to my mouth isn't that
ironic
why do you guys not like that here just
no I've never had someone be like can
you get that microphone close if you
listened with headphones you would feel
the difference
interesting yeah that might be why I
think I was I was experimenting with
being a little more soft-spoken and your
podcast was like the new me you mean the
old you is back
trying to be like a little more like I'm
this guy now okay I like three years
into podcasting and I'm gonna try to be
appealing I have I have a podcast trick
for you tell me it's better if you have
headphones you could hear but honestly
this does it if here tell me something
and then I'm going to show you what
something you could do uh I like the
color of your shirt thank you
that was sexy one finger on the cheek
and before you say something
um
okay
you look like you feel sorry for me
more so than normal
see that's what that offers that offers
the person opposite them feeling they're
so confident and accepting of themselves
that the real person opposite comes out
so whatever you're feeling was something
I think maybe you could work on
your balls have dropped since last time
I saw you like your voice is big like
voice of God energy right stay there
when I'm on somebody else's podcast I
like to show up and when somebody comes
on mine I like to give them the space to
show well it is tricky because when it
is your own podcast you're like I can
always fix this later no no no it's when
it's my it's not about me it's about you
Whitney we spent most of your podcast
with me adjusting my microphone no I
wanted to sound but I just want to make
sure are you gonna be okay with my mic
being here for my podcast I have no
problem you run your ship however you
want that okay so the little trick where
you just when I asked you a question and
you responded
more quiet reminded me of when you're in
a fight with a guy and he gaslights You
by you being like so why are we out till
three in the morning and he's like I
don't get why you're yelling
when he starts talking quieter and
quieter so it seems like you're yelling
I understand I hate that I must feel bad
I just don't know why you're freaking
out yeah I mean you're the one that's
losing your temper right now I'm being
really calm you know the problem I have
with that they're telling you that they
don't understand instead of trying to
ask questions to learn I would say
what's bothering you
what are you feeling right now you came
home at three in the morning I could see
how that could probably do that what
does that make you feel makes you feel I
was doing something I shouldn't be doing
well you told me you're gonna be home at
10.
that's fair yeah no I know it's fair the
problem is I work late and I thought I
would be home at 10 but I should have
done a better job staying in touch with
you throughout the night and telling you
that things keep getting pushed back and
I'm sorry so you were working until 3
A.M it's working till one then we went
and got some to eat why'd you look over
there
that's my main thing so so let me
turn off the camera so I was offering a
space for you and even in that you're
now what are you doing why are you doing
that for me when a guy when you ask him
a question or a girl anyone and they
like look over here I'm always like
why'd you look over there why are you so
concerned with what I'm doing instead of
just being here with me because what
you're doing looking around I'm in a new
space there's five cameras on you thank
God me and you right now I like that you
keep popping in and out but I'm still
here I'm always I'm always around within
the Improv bit
you know what I looked away because I'm
like I guess maybe no that's no okay
what do you think I'm lying about I
think you were not working till three in
the morning now a question are you no
budding me in this improv game or are
you yes ending the fact that you're
untrusting we'll be right back
me too I think you and I get along yeah
I think you and I we get along although
at first glance I would think we are
dramatically incredibly different people
why do different people
that's a really good my mom and dad are
so separate they're best friends yeah I
think that I think that well it's
interesting because I've never really
like like I think you are
self-proclaimed like kind of neurotic
right which is do you find that as an
insult because I don't see that as an
insult I think detail-oriented being
sensitive I think that's cool I I don't
know where self-proclaimed comes from I
don't I think that a lot of people refer
to me as neurotic but I just say you're
neurotic I think it should be
self-diagnosed I don't know if someone's
like he's being neurotic like when
people say like she's neurotic it's
basically well
or you cheated do you know what I mean
it's just a character description
Whitney Cummings 21 neurotic loves
Batman but just a Christian Bale version
okay can you give people context on what
that is people think we're nuts we'll
swipe to it has that edible kicked in
um why are you throwing putting me on
blast oh dude are we not public about
that no it's okay I know in Edibles a
lot of the pandemic and I should have
put it on blast I talk about it and I do
them on the podcast sometimes and the
cat's out of the bag I took it right
when we started so it won't kick in for
a little but Rory Scoville told me
something once no we did a show
in Alaska and
um I don't remember kicked in
what do you mean you mean there it just
sounds not true
um and I don't remember if I got high
before or after but we were talking
about
going on stage high and that's totally
fine if that you're good at that and you
like to do that I love to do that okay
he said something that I very much
agreed with
which was
don't tell the audience you're high as
an excuse like if you want to play in
this world and saying I'm high for for a
reason to let them ensure but to tell
people you're high
no no I'm just High like almost it feels
like it's an excuse 100 and when I get
high I feel like I'm able to do it in a
very professional sure it makes it well
you're creative so it makes you better
it makes us more confident more not me
but you different I love it I don't know
better but you ever playing with friends
of course you are and then you get in
this little natural high you know I
believe you like chemicals would you say
a little dopamine a little oxytocin you
just I'll take it I've been known the
dabble yeah there's the High
um and that fun that you have in that
high you could get naturally we'd almost
always gets me there so like
why not that is honestly it makes me so
jealous because I can't do that I had to
stop smoking weed in the end of January
everyone I was very aware that I had
like a manic episode after my mom died I
think maybe weed with grief is maybe not
the best combination possibly
um but weed for me
makes me think I need to solve like
major Global crimes right like major
like I was looking for the fifth of
Michael Jackson's elephants for like two
and a half weeks like driving up there
with a drone did you find anything
I'm pretty close
that's the I mean the the only problem
is I am great a Great sleuth but it
makes me be like I was scheduling a zoom
call with a maritime lawyer to get to
the bottom of the Scientology boats
right so just so you know I'm scheduling
a zoom call with a maritime lawyer it
does make you sound a little out of
touch with a common folk so what I'm
saying is that's what happens when I
smoke weed I
chill and I write more jokes I'm like I
start scheduling Zoom calls about
International maritime law well I do
think we just came up with good merch
idea I'm a great sleuth
that sleuth life yeah but I don't know
maybe that's just my personality I'm
already kind of an intense person I
wouldn't say that
like it doesn't show but it does
sometimes chill me out in a way that's
not helpful I chose what is what do you
look like chilled out let's do a little
improv game you ready how much is your
debt but I got it that's what happens
when I get chilled out what yeah how
much is your debt I start paying
people's loans off man if only I had
debt I would ask that yeah if you had
been around me in January so I I kind of
like it doesn't benefit me Whitney we
don't do you say sir sorry sir
I would like to play an improv game with
you where we're both just real chill I
don't mean whoa bro where are the
Funyuns I'm Stoner chill I just mean
like okay
what'd you do today
uh waiting for you because I thought you
were coming at 11. and then I was in a
Virgo spiral I do feel a little
defensive on that 11 thing you know what
I it's so funny because you know when
like well let's let them in on what that
means I thought excuse me we were
scheduled for 11 30. Whitney thought it
was 11.
go on Mom brain I am pregnant and I am
doing weird things I've never done
before like scheduling on a half hour I
don't know what that was I think what
happened was you said 11 and I was
thinking yeah but then I want to get the
coffee and then can we do 11 30 and you
said yes okay
so I think what happened was I'm still
carrying guilt from being late to your
podcast and when I thought you were a
little late I was like yes oh I actually
really but I was I also told you I was
so early that I was waiting down the
mountain that you live on so I could
have reception and I was just on my
phone like ETA and I'm thinking like I
mean I've been here for 20 minutes but I
I don't want I didn't want to impose
dude I know and I kind of God damn it of
course I'm wrong but I like being early
as the power man yeah you said Power
movement I thought that was interesting
because I think a lot of people feel
that being late is a power move and that
was that's very early off I think being
late is the opposite you lose all your
power when you show up early like there
is a
who cares uh
uh using um story about when Ellen
showed up to this like dinner party like
45 minutes early and the hosts were like
getting out of the shower like they
hadn't even put the like in the way
you're just like running around you know
serving someone because they decide to
show up early is such a bigger power I
think 45 minutes early is
it's too early so that's the ultimate
power move I think showing up within 10
minutes 10 to 5 5 to 10 minutes early
yeah yeah because if because the other
person needs to be ready five minutes
early yeah so I like to be a little
early but hmm well you let me know how
the weed journey is going I'm very
jealous stop sorry gosh you know what
Ron funches did this to me once when uh
I was like are you stoned he was like
you just ruined it for me I'm like I
didn't realize if someone's stoned
you're not allowed to talk about it
because like you're not ostensibly
stoned you probably get like more clear
and just more no become a better version
of yourself buy obstensibly what does
that word mean just obvious by from what
I can see do you ever use words that are
better or easier words but like when
people say Superfluous I'm just like to
say it doesn't matter Superfluous is a
great word but great Superfluous is not
a perfect synonym
um doesn't matter
no it means extra that's a Superfluous
jacket you don't need it you already
have a jacket on that's superfluous
you could just say you don't need it
yeah but that's three words it's
actually faster to say so perfume lists
don't need it you could say extra that's
like extra or unnecessary when people
say that word it makes me think of if
you ask somebody how they're doing and
if you ask me how I'm doing how are you
doing I'm good how are you and if you
don't go back with good and instead say
well
I'm doing well it's fine if you opened
with well today maybe like I'm well like
what do we have I think like it's
Superfluous Vikings it feels like you're
bragging it's like eating an apple
outside when have you ever asked someone
how they were and they said well many
times really everyone I know is always
like uh uh am I you know hanging in
there you're like all right bye oh you
hang around with people that aren't so
sad well you know when you ask them how
they're doing and they need to they
won't just say I'm fine like this is a
formality what we're doing like this is
performative and they're like yeah you
know it's just kind of and you're like
oh but I didn't sign up for whatever
this was I am the opposite I actually
talk about on stage the the rules of how
you're doing rules and how uncomfortable
it is and how manufactured manipulative
and if somebody if I ask somebody it's
because
like tell me something
if I ask you how you're doing you better
say great and we're moving on it's my
home doing how are you doing
do you want the truth well I kind of
asked it like I really want to know the
answer which you oh I love that but if I
go hey how are you that just means what
do you want from me I'll say I would go
like how are you
that means I want to know the answer
because you're squinted well I just went
like how I'm my body language is
squaring up to you and I'm not walking
past you it sounds like a Native
American giving me an Indian name how
how
are you
as a Native American writing for Yoda
giving somebody a name how are you
I got to you and they were just like
yeah
and that ended up being your name but I
think body language is more if you're
walking by being like hey how are you
that doesn't mean stop me and tell me
how your prozac's not mixing well you
know what I do when someone gives me how
are you when it's just they're not
meaning it I'll maybe I'll say good hell
maybe I'll say well I don't ask back
oh that's you don't get in there 45
minutes early
I think I would go so ask if it's a if
it's a walker buyer ask me ask me let me
show you
um hey Rick how are you hey Whitney I'm
good
I'm good too thanks
real good Whitney I would probably be
like uh no mirror neurons over there bud
good to see you Whitney
I don't believe you okay um but wait I
like that I like that do you want the
truth I do like that
you told me something I was here last
time I said something that you like what
was that but wait can we do this
actually role play because I want to
make sure that this is something I
really do want to sign up for so um do
you want to cut to a sponsor uh better
help always we both need it
um so I'm doing well will you do the uh
do the truth how are you
want the truth
what am I signing up for
space we'll be right back I would like
have to know is that like the two minute
version of like 10 minutes yeah I asked
that sometimes and sometimes if I'm
gonna tell somebody like sometimes I
have little stories or anecdotes and I
say I have this thing I want to tell you
it's going to take like two minutes
are you into it I love I love uh
managing expectations yes because
because if you say yes and and I'm now
telling it and I haven't hit all the
Beats yet or whatever I'm thinking like
should I keep going yeah yeah but once I
say yes I'm like I got two minutes I'll
give you the light if you go past two
minutes yeah yeah because I do I hate
putting pressure on people it really
stresses me out for some reason so being
pregnant has been really tricky so
people will go like how are you and I'm
like I'm pregnant but but they're don't
you don't need to do anything about it I
get the first part I think the second
part is something we could zoom in on
hmm
to assume that they feel that they need
to do something about it no where people
like that's great you don't have to ask
Instagram like you don't have
to have to respond to most people I
think kind of like who is it what kind
what kind and I'm always like you don't
have to do this but maybe they just want
to and my brain thinks I'm trapping or
maybe they have to they feel like they
have to do it and that's that's their
thing I was cornered the other night
with a hey how are you and a I was just
cheated on and and it and my marriage is
over and I was just like I did you ask
them how they were I just walking by
quick but you asked that's on you I know
I wasn't then you have
you have to be careful with your how are
you yeah I think we need to be
intentional with a lot of things but
that is one of them and and I believe
and I know that working with horses has
really helped me because I have a hard
time with social cues but like you also
got to read body language I feel like I
feel like you just started working with
horses and your managers told you find
natural ways to work in that you're
working with working with nurses don't
have managers
turn the cameras back off
you sound like an asshole I would say
nay all I'm saying is when you say like
I said I've been working with horses it
was a throwaway you know my dad owns a
rug store and the thing is I want people
to know is I love home decor it's just
it feels like you're forcing it in
if you're looking for just the right
flooring you need choices and at
Marshall Carpet One you'll find
thousands of choices
including carpet
Hardwood
rugs
and luxury vinyl
so make the right choice and visit
Marshall Carpet One in rug gallery
and we promise with more than 50 years
as a family-owned business
we've got you covered
[Music]
and we're back I hate it when you
finally say something relatable and then
they make you sound like you're an
asshole what's an asshole about working
with horses no I'm kidding no but I'm
just saying I have a hard time with
social cues and at least 70 percent of
communication is non-verbal and it
drives me nuts when someone only focuses
on the verbal so uh I don't know about
that statistic about 70 I know a lot of
it is non-verbal I also have learned
that that's their way of communicating
here's an example
you're dating a guy right and he's got a
different love language than you that
doesn't mean you have to have his it
just means you understand his right yeah
so when other people communicate like
this
that's their communication
well I was just calling back what are
your what is your love language
it's really hard to have different ones
I find
My love language is uh touching words
about information I mean
you receive love with words of
affirmation and physical touch yeah
probably in that order and You Give Love
probably the same Give Love Actually the
same oh gosh
what's the matter you're so wonderful
save my nightmare show me see I'm a acts
of service and uh well I would love to
get you some headphones
can I ask you something is there because
I know you know a lot why are we leaving
this we don't have to let's stay on this
for a minute I think I think this is our
audience would like if we could stay on
something for 30 seconds okay you did
this when I was on your podcast well you
did this while you were on my podcast
when something when I have nothing more
to say on a topic I'm like let's pivot
great well you have nothing more to say
okay okay great are you familiar with
the expression below the line of
employees okay so no okay um below the
line is what you call that's not what I
do which is I find insulting
conversationally no okay so here we are
right now we're talking about
communication verbal non-verbal Love
Languages oh that's on the same track
once we start talking about like
something else the horses or like we
could stay there for a minute but if it
doesn't Bob back up we could just say
hey we're below the line let's get back
to where the line was sure so sometimes
I like to visualize conversations
establish what that line is once we
close that line we start a new one sure
love languages
when you know what is your um and I
believe I don't know what you refer to
him as but I really referred him as my
man right now you're my dude what how
what is his love language to give this
is acts of service right that's right
it's not words of affirmation he's very
he's like um uh what's his name from
Princess Bride he's like
gonna wash the car and do all the stuff
that I didn't even ask him to do even
though who was in The Princess Bride
what's his name Carrie always his
character
uh what like who's just like polishing
Saddles and doing stuff Wesley he loves
he does acts of service which I really
appreciate but he doesn't communicate
about when he's gonna do them but he
does know if the if the woman expresses
her needs he will do as she wishes
will she not and that's why if you tell
me that what you need is acts of service
now I know but the acts of service need
to be something I number one value and
number two I know it's happening so I
can't find my computer for 20 minutes
and he's like oh well I'm updating it
I'm like well you have to tell me you're
taking it because I don't know where it
is and I just had a zoom call you know
so he's like we're struggling with
communication and even when you're doing
something so nice and so helpful it's
not nice or helpful if I don't know
what's actually happening if you know
that somebody gets off by doing
something else yeah and you know that
that's how they connect and then they do
it does that then mean more to you or is
it like that's not how I like to receive
things I'm out as long as there's not a
scorecard so acts of service doesn't
count if two months later you go well I
took your dog to the vet and this is how
you're gonna act like that's not sure
acts of service that's score keeping and
codependence
I think that's resentment and feeling
like the other person isn't putting in
the same trying the same that you feel
like you are sure and I think that also
then comes down to once again lack of
communication yeah because if if if you
were to say well I did blah blah blah
blah blah if I could realize not oh
she's keeping score but oh you feel like
I'm not reciprocating it to you right
right let's figure out how I could do
that better yep and then oh you want me
to find your laptop for you that's what
that means and I think we got to learn
other people's communication types and
that's the point I was making is not to
hey what are we doing no I'm just
looking down that's why I feel like why
I brought this up when you're like oh
yeah but communication is nonverbal
that's their communication sure
communication is my primary I think
growing up and now called home where
there was a lot of uh um dissonance
between what was being said and what was
being done growing up and like going to
church where it said treat people a
certain way and then you get home and it
would be completely the opposite I had
to start looking I had to stop listening
to words because words I was lied to a
lot as a kid I also feel I don't have
that but I also feel like if what's said
and what is done is the same thing then
you could listen to what's said as a
shorthand until those things are
separate but it's always what's done
when I was a kid as soon as that stuff
started getting in Congress I was like
words are meaningless this is a mislead
don't listen to the words it'll fail you
every time and I just started trying to
analyze people's behavior and understand
things and probably to a fault and sure
so I can't really uh listen to what
someone's saying unless I take into
account how they're saying also I want
to make sure that we don't do the whole
thing on therapy stuff I also want to
bust balls and talk about fucking
fucking and like other stuff I'm in
therapy
and I don't think we're even talking
about therapy wow this is more just like
look I have been diagnosed with all
kinds of things I know you're kind of a
master at this I'm still trying to
figure out if it's because I was told at
a young age I had Asperger's I think I
was just not communicated with properly
at all my life or socialized or I had to
kind of like disassociate what's
properly mean everybody communicates
different totally but I just didn't get
a lot of eye contact I had to learn how
to make eye contact like six years ago I
had to go to somebody because I used to
look at the side of someone's head
instead of like in their eyes and men
would always think I was looking at
their hairline and freak out
so I had I would just look I thought
this was a normal place to look right
Rock and money is a personal finance app
that finds and cancels your unwanted
subscriptions monitors your spending and
helps you lower your bills all in one
place oh this is this is my dream this
is like um you know the feeling you get
when you clean out the lint in the dryer
yes or like Papa zit and it's like a
silly string streamer
yeah or like oh God I mean like the
number of subscriptions I have that I
just haven't canceled because I forgot
they were there those little Eight
dollar twelve dollars little sneaky ones
like I'll I'll go through my credit card
bills every now and then and I'll be
like why do I still have a subscription
to TiVo so I'm still paying the Goo Goo
Dolls web store for their newsletter
like how long is this how many fan club
memberships how long wait quibby I'm
still paying for quibby why am I still
subscribed to Lisa Marie's only fans I
think she did I don't know the whole
thing this is like a complete Game
Changer so let's talk about how they do
it first of all like any brilliant
companies worth trying that you can
trust you can try it free for 30 days
just enough time to try it and then
completely forget about it
um in fact over 80 percent of people
have subscriptions they forgot about
that's my brand you could be wasting
money and not even realizing it rocket
money helps you find those forgotten
subscriptions so you can stop paying for
the ones you don't use because you're
not a dumb dumb and that money adds up
rocket money also helps you manage all
your finances in one place and
automatically categorize your expenses
so you can easily track your budget in
real time also get alerted if anything
looks off over three million people have
used rocket money saving the average
person up to 720 a year cancel unwanted
subscription and manage your expenses
the easy way by going to rocketmoney.com
Whitney that's rocketmoney.com slash
Whitney everyone unsubscribes to our
podcast immediately
I have a joke where I would talk about I
kissed late in life
um and I didn't know how to kiss and I
couldn't ask people I was too late and I
didn't know if I if I go top lift the
top lip and bottom of the bottom look or
do you do it every other lip
um and I just made me think of that if
you alternate right I can't tell you
what's the answer
um uh it doesn't matter you bite the
tablet
um I'm a bottom lip biter BLB cute yeah
I feel like there's usually more meat on
the bottom lip I think there is an
epidemic of too much tongue and kissing
now and too much wetness I think that
yeah if you want if you want if you want
the the the the the there's cheat code
on how to lose me we did it if I don't
have to put on Vaseline when we're done
I thank you very much for that reason I
am out I just don't like when there's
just like a wet like a ring around your
mouth you know what I mean yeah I get do
you kiss your dogs yes that's the
problem yes and no but I like a nice
closed mouth for a while yeah you start
off over the warm-up and if you're
kissing for 30 seconds I don't need to
get trapped but much like a great story
sure I want our kissing to heighten and
while if we're making out and deepen
heighten as in get bigger and more where
is there room to go the width of saliva
to get bigger yeah but the problem is
women wear makeup you know and in
sometimes if it doesn't match perfectly
I don't need there to be like a line
yeah sure that I look like Curious
George where there's like a lighter
circle around my mouth and then it's
like I think I get it bronzer
um well when I'm kissing my lady
how long have you been with your lady
um
like a half a year okay
depending on when this comes out way to
make it seem longer
um well it depends like how long have we
known each other how long have we been
like dating official what's the title I
mean oh my god well I gave you a generic
answer because that's none of your
fucking business I don't need people
knowing exactly and then what makes you
go like I want to date this girl
um
I like her she's funny she's playful you
meet girls every day all the time I'm
just fascinated like what
what was different about her than other
girls
um
she laughed at your jokes she you said
different
you said different no I'm just curious
like what made her different what made
her stand out what made you go I'm going
to commit and be monogamous with this
person
committing with somebody like I'm just
curious and I asked because not to
interrupt sorry sometimes you kind of
like to interrupt but go on welcome
welcome to the podcast
real quick to interrupt do that I see
you see like the way I'm doing right now
how the momentum is going away like that
I see one second one second I'm just
trying to interrupt go ahead it's called
Helping first of all it's not
interrupting it's called Helping um the
way you help horses we know
with the
big girls tend to sometimes you go to or
break up with the guy or guy breaks up
with you and you see that is everybody
to answer you
you see the woman that they move on to
next and you're like her
right why well first of all to move on
to next usually is a long period for me
okay
um after a breakup I feel like for
months even if if I like I'd be cheating
if I'm with somebody else still because
like
I'm still grieving this thing and it
feels weird
um so it takes me a while and I also
notice it still it takes me a while when
getting into a relationship too okay
like
just adapting takes a while I'm I'm in a
relationship so being single that's a
weird thing to understand and then once
I'm single being in a relationship feels
like a weird thing and then once you get
in it
or once I feel like okay I think I could
do this and I want to do this with this
person then to make that commitment
that's like a I'm sure it is for a lot
of people but that feels like a really
big deal to me it feels like um
it feels like what I imagine it feels
like to get engaged for the average
person like we're deciding we're doing
this
there's no backing out of course people
even get divorced but like once you make
that decision it's a really big deal do
you think um this is partly because you
come from a happily married home of
parents who are still together I call
this the trauma of having happily
married parents man even good stuff's
trauma to you huh I just be the people
that I know your next book should be I'm
not fine
well it says
it says and other lies yeah right
um I do feel like the people that I know
that come from these like happy homes
are kind of like struggling with being
in relationships and like committing
because they wanted to be perfect
because they've actually seen that
template I think my issue not issue but
I think my like uh
trust and okay let's do this comes from
uh not my parents but I
didn't
have friends growing up really
um
and I didn't really realize that because
I wasn't it wasn't like uh
fuck you Glassman take a hike everyone
was nice enough I just like oh they
would include me and then they wouldn't
and then like oh I could play over and
then when everyone else would go in
their house Rick you're not allowed in
and it's like I I don't understand what
my Dynamic is
in so many relationships with my brother
sometimes he was nice often he wasn't
with my neighbors with the kids I went
to school with they were all friends on
my street but I was like not invited to
the birthday parties so like are we
friends are you my girlfriend what is
this dude this is stumbling on some like
gold mine of insight because I see so
many people grappling with their
childhood and their parents and I'm like
dude the trauma of friends in middle
school friends and the trauma of prom
the fact that prom is even legal the
fact that it is just kids at the most
vulnerable time of their life when they
have acne they have braces trying to
figure out if someone's gonna ask them
something or they're gonna get rejected
or their best friend is going to get
asked by the person they get a crush on
when everyone's hormonal hormones are
going insane the Mercurial nature of you
know I don't know about guys in their
tree house but the Mean Girl thing where
you know when I moved to Roanoke
Virginia I switched schools in the
middle of
um whatever a semester went in all of a
sudden showed up at this time any
Catholic School in Roanoke Virginia I
had a uniform I had the wrong color
shirt I went in They're laughing at me
you know I'm sorry I couldn't hear you
say it again
girls were nice to me one day they were
mean to me the other day and I'm like I
come from an alcoholic home with trauma
sexual abuse this this is what you
showing up the prom I come from an
alcoholic home sexual abuse my name is
Whitney Cummings and I am not
I'm mad and like that did so much more
damage I feel like in a lot of ways you
got to learn these things man because
your parents like they screw up and they
love you and then they don't and it's
kind of like okay that's who you are but
you guys like you can't even invite me
to your party like you're conniving and
they tell me the reason is because their
parents said no and I grew up believing
I remember a kid I called him
maybe once a week for a year
to come over
and
I just believed he was always busy
but then doing what happened my kids
don't have anything it doesn't matter I
believed everything when I was a kid I
had no idea people lied I'm working on
this this bit now where I talk about I
don't know if my parents are liars or
human because I'm realizing oh people
just say things to make it easier and
it's not very intuitive to me I have I
am however very naturally skeptic to
things so I'll ask a lot of questions to
try to figure out but like when I
remember he told me that one time he
said his mom said he couldn't blah blah
blah and I said
could my mom talk to your mom
and he said okay and I gave my mom the
phone my mom Champions me I I really
think that she should be a manager or
mine at least I'm in the market she
would be great and they might be moving
to California sick
so my mom
talks to her on the phone and ultimately
told me that Bob I don't remember what
it was but I've been as I'm talking
about the stuff on stage I'm like
revisiting it and I'm like coming from
an adult perspective and I now realize
oh
his mom probably told my mom he doesn't
want to play with Ricky and my mom
didn't want to tell me that now if I
were to ask my mom there's no way she
even remembers that do you think that
the other kid when he put his mom on he
was like
there's a world where
that's all true or there was a world
where he was a busy kid Lemonade Stand
possible I'm just saying I'm just saying
I
I also preface by saying I do a bit on
this because I get insecure like I'm
forcing something but it's stuff I'm
like working out now but like I look
back and it's like
I had no friends as a kid and I never
knew it until now like I said like I
just thought everyone was busy I had the
confidence that people like me
but I did I didn't grow up feeling
insecure or not included I mean
subconsciously in some way like me I
didn't know we were poor until recently
you still think you're poor you fucking
weirdo that is true but growing up I
thought we were Rich because my mom
drank wine right you know it's a rich
thing I mean have you seen eight mile
wait surely like I would see wine in a
glass and I was like oh look it up she
worked at Bloomingdale's so we would be
talking stores like I thought that was
our stuff I don't know like I
um and there was a lot of keeping up
with the Joneses and pretending we had
she wore like a lot of makeup were you
were do they have money at first and
then it went away so they're keeping up
no no no wasn't that because we would
have like a nice car for like a month
and then it would get taken away but we
it was there you know so it was like
things would get impounded things would
come they would go you know my dad he
did this whatever he did there was like
collateral was a big thing well if you
don't want to say it we could just cut
to a clip I don't just got to that's on
your podcast no a couple of stuff your
dad did yeah no I don't know I would get
like for a holiday I would get like some
really nice jewelry that was like right
so how did you guys afford this stuff
then this was in collateral deals from
like loan sharking or something like a
gambler kind of kind of but it would
seem you know there was like a I saw
Burberry trench coat once and you know I
was like that's sorry like you know I
don't know my mom because when you work
at a department store you can get 30 30
which means you can get like 20 off my
mom sold perfume worked at Macy's you
get 20 off your 20 off your 20. totally
yeah so I used to do that too I used to
be a same girl great my mom was that for
years and that's what I did for a while
this is crazy
crazy credit and
have to talk to strangers do crowd work
anything from starting being like a
perfume man if you if you saw my mom in
action oh I'm the best I think you would
have her on a roast I I bet she is the
best saleswoman and here's the reason my
mom doesn't sell a product she fulfills
a need you know how hard it is to
convince somebody they don't smell good
hold on one sec let me see give me your
arm for a second my mom would do that
stuff and she'll rub the lotion so it
mixes with the oils in your body it
smells different on everybody and you're
unique and you're special it smells
different on you but she'll smell it and
I've seen her she'll get like I'll be
honest I that I don't think this is the
one for you and she'll say stuff like
that you have to do that you have to and
then also it's big to do like no no
don't put it directly on your skin walk
through it I'm gonna Spritz it was this
with you I just talked about on a
podcast I don't remember if it was with
you perfume is done I hate it I can't
stand it it's too strong if you need it
one spray walk in yeah but I can't stand
you can also spray your clothes and then
put the clothes on
like this yeah or just put it in your
hair I'm gonna do something that is
really tactless on a podcast because it
messes up momentum but I feel
comfortable with you okay and here's the
buzzer
that's right I'm gonna use it okay
I need to use the bathroom okay great
and then when you come back I want to
maybe blow your mind about this kid that
you thought was busy
okay
I just took a shit
that's the title of this episode Rick
lastman takes a shit you title episodes
tell me when I get back I'll be right
back
[Music]
you guys have seen the liquid death cans
you've seen them on my podcast you've
seen births and toms and you've seen us
just generally look cooler than you and
is it because we're cooler than you
you tell me I'm wearing an airbrush
unicorn shirt that I got at Etsy Bert
and Tom do they have any reason looking
cooler than you given their bodies and
faces and choices don't think so one
liquid death can turns a four into a ten
so liquid death my favorite water
because their philosophy is about death
to plastic okay they are as far as I
know the only water company that is not
making plastic nonsense why do you think
the orcas are so pissed off dude liquid
death is my favorite they've got uh all
these new flavors they've got all these
fancy new caffeine beverages also the
armless Palmer which is so funny uh is a
Arnold Palmer you can find liquid that's
healthy beverages on Amazon or at a
retailer near you or in Amazon boxes in
front of my house I have like 500. good
for you listeners you're gonna get 20
off your first liquid death apparel
purchase exclusively at liquiddeath.com
Whitney exclusions May apply
liquidat.com
another thing about the kid that didn't
want to hang out this is just a slight
curveball not on his side seems like a
punk oh I'm friends with him now no way
yeah really yeah I was never not I just
wanted to be has he been able to
corroborate the story about how I never
taught I talked about this on a podcast
before but I've never talked to him
you gotta talk to him yeah I guess I
should there's no way he remembers this
I will you remember it so why wouldn't
he because this this was something that
like conditioned me to understand people
gaslighting you no people uh I mean
that's just the only way they knew how
to communicate he was a kid did you ever
ask your mom what his mom said why am I
so invested my mom wouldn't remember
I don't like liars dude that's my only I
don't like liars but maybe he wasn't
lying or maybe he was lying for a
different reason I used to lie about
people coming to my house because I was
embarrassed about my house and I was
embarrassed that we like didn't have
food in the fridge and that you know my
mom drank so a lot of times I would say
I couldn't hang out even when I could
and I feel like I didn't have a lot of
friends anyway because I was switching
schools all the time but I was
embarrassed to have kids over are you
embarrassed now is that why you have
such a lovely home
I mean I mean look having comedians over
they're gonna find anything to make fun
of but I when I was a kid I was super
embarrassed about what was in the fridge
and like do you have friends that are
Comics that are roast comics and that's
why you feel that way because I feel
like my comic friends don't make fun of
a lot of stuff
like you're I I idea of comics are
making fun of I just get exhausted by
being made fun of something like it just
I think for me maybe it's because you're
stupid idiot yeah that's probably why
this could think of a joke just fucking
make fun of her well you're a stupid
idiot by the way that's actually the
next roast we should just have you just
like Hey so uh hey Jim Norton you're a
stupid idiot listen I I I we talked
about this on mine if you would honestly
have a question can I just liberate both
of us for a second no if you were to
actually have me on yes go ahead why do
we have to do this thing where if we're
about to say something we go I actually
talked about this on something recently
same reason why I say that I did a bit
on it because it we don't like lying and
if we retell something if we retail
that's that's a that's a very fine line
witness but no one would know I disagree
your story about the kid that couldn't
hang out is very different than a bit no
but if I talked about it okay I still I
don't want to say I struggle with this
but it's still it's still an obstacle
for me but for
eight ten years of doing stand-up
I had a very hard time repeating stuff I
would do different sets all the time
yeah
and the reason was I felt like I was
lying I already said this I already did
this I already told people this that's
like what we do for a living we say the
same thing every night and make it feel
fresh sure that's the craft not the the
mindset behind it right I've had
conversations with some people like who
cares that's what you're supposed to
most people go to see you they're like I
hope he's done this before and practice
it but I've talked to a fair amount of
comedians who also say yeah I know you
have to get past that they felt it too I
feel that way interpersonally as well
like if I'm telling you something that I
just told somebody else I feel like I
just want to let you know I said this
already I just feel like we are so hard
on ourselves that I'm just looking to
kind of liberate myself a little bit
from the places of how hard I am on
myself I think I just because I only
around people who are also hard on
themselves which is good I realized when
I go on a podcast and I'm just saying
something if you know um when Riley Reid
was on she said about how when she got
into porn um the first time she was on
her period and they told her to put a
sponge in her pussy and I'm like I was
just talking about this I couldn't just
talk about it I had to say like oh yeah
I just talked about this on Tana Mojo's
pie have you seen that Montage of Lady
Gaga interviews where she said the same
thing 18 times that's my nightmare there
you go there can be a hundred people in
the room and 99 don't believe in you you
can have 100 people in the room 99 don't
believe in you there can be a hundred
people in the room and 99 don't believe
in you and just one does you know there
can be a hundred people in the room and
99 don't believe in you and just one
does that's my name she said you know I
just said this 16 times we would be like
all right she's just on the Press right
what if I mean they could have cut it
out too sure they could still come but I
don't think you'll be cutting that out
of this but don't you think we should be
so lucky if people actually were like
I've heard him say this before I've
heard her say this before if you want to
talk about being grateful for something
with the cons that come with it sure
yeah but if you're able to avoid those
cons by just prefacing things if
everything you know I was actually just
talked I actually just went to the
bathroom the other day but could I go to
the bathroom now like it's like okay
okay okay yeah I'm just curious if we do
it for each other it shouldn't be like I
don't want you to think I do it for me
or if we're doing it for the audience
because I do it with no cameras I do it
too and I think when I hear someone do
it I'm like no one cares why don't you
don't have to tell on yourself but then
I do it like why you're so sensitive to
it because you regrets about it yeah you
know I was actually talking to somebody
the other day um about you know it's
like
this doesn't take that long to say that
it's true no it's true and sometimes
it's just us going and I've said this
before let me just get my shame out of
the way or let me just let you know that
if you've heard it I know
Esther oh which by the way I wanna also
taking advantage to promote I'm doing a
podcast with that Serpa bitsky nice
called Rick and Esther have a time great
check it out and all the things
um but uh Esther
can I ask I'm going to ask you a
question can I ask you something please
that's what she does all the time it's
like that's right I have something I
want to ask you I'm going to ask a
question now
she'll say that before her question but
don't you think sometimes when people
say that they're coming up with it as
they're saying it I think that she's
trying to find a 24 7. but what I'm
saying is
like if I do that I don't have the
question if I go you're actually funny I
have to there's something I really wanna
because like because I'm saying like
literally my only job here is to ask you
questions so if I go can I ask you a
question like that's the conceit of this
whole thing it means I'm trying to come
up with one and I just need to like just
put some dribble in I want to go back to
the roast thing maybe she knows your
triggers yes no I think she that's just
her that was I'm saying that is another
example of like oh I just said this the
other day like they're saying it for
themselves yeah they're finding a safety
to ask a question or to repeat the story
can I ask you one question though about
that stuff and about being lied to and
trying to figure out if you're live
being lied to
um do I tell my kid about Santa Claus
because I'm really torn about it and I
don't want to yeah I understand I don't
want to lie to my kid at all so do you
think that any of our parents lying to
us about the Easter Bunny and tooth
fairy and all that did any damage no
hot date no not at all I could
understand that and I don't think it's
wrong but also you are taking away
something so where do you think the
parent way came from of not know ing are
we together are we not together just
from friends in high school you said it
when words and actions don't line up
um and when there's inconsistencies when
when this is okay today but it's not
tomorrow and in as an adult I recognize
there are some times where you're
supposed to you know shake the hand and
be a certain way but also like that's
just because that's what people said but
nobody teaches you that at least not me
so sometimes
I have uh I have a a metaphor that
expands past jokes but I have said this
on a podcast before and I want to pitch
it to you and this is something I
learned today you said everything
sometimes you tell a joke
and it gets a laugh
and
are you good I'm just trying to plug in
my computer sorry it's not charging for
some reason I don't know what's going on
got it
why is my Mac asleep
well I mean maybe it's been listening to
you for the past hour
why does nothing work I'm trying to like
is that even plugged in what's on your
computer it's a list of questions you've
asked me three is this the not brand
name dude the ones that they bought I am
somebody who uses you use a brand name
charger honestly we got the biggest I
just had this conversation with my
girlfriend the other day I almost caught
on fire last night because he got one
from Hudson News and it overheated right
next to my baby and you almost got
caught on fire is that you spend 80 for
the apple one and I'm like cool
yeah you buy the Apple chargers for the
Apple product that's it period the end I
don't know what to tell you and he's
like well I don't like being taken is
that what Riley Reid said the first time
she did porn
yeah I just all I want is for computer
to charge cool now you have two wishes
left in charge computer was it worth it
Pat and Nick they both do this thing
where they take chords and they save
them a thing instead of just one's dead
well some people save horses some say
chords but we don't like no no we might
need this board one day so I have a
whole Satchel of cords that don't work
and I'm like can we please just
thought about selling those as merch
I'm gonna hang but you're gonna find me
hanging from one of these chords one day
homage to the star is born with Lady
Gaga no I can't now I'm gonna have to
watch that clip of her saying the same
thing over and over again that is the
most cringed nightmare to me are you a
big fan of hers uh love Lady Gaga I
don't I don't like I'm not like a
ladybug yeah how'd you know about
ladybugs I don't know like what's your
thing ladybugs monsters a little monster
no I I like I like when someone kills in
one area and then kills in another area
too it makes me a little bit jealous but
it makes me hopeful why do you only kill
in one area no like you know like like
Madonna being a big musician and then
she doesn't League of Their Own yeah
that's a great um you know can I tell
you I was gonna say desperately saving
Susan if you realize something that
it's not just Madonna it's not just Lady
Gaga we are all members of
the All-American team yep we come from
cities near and far would you agree I
hate you yes we got
Canadians Irish ones in swedes we're all
for one we're One for All We're All
American wait America is a Canadian
sorry real quick though I think it's let
me interrupt I think it's really
important that we bring women's baseball
back speak on that in fact yell at me as
long as they're trans women I will buy
tickets I think that there should be a
baseball league that allows women
whether they're trans or not trans
we could have the national league the
American League in the trans League
uh-huh I'm sorry transatlantic where we
have it to where it's like we have you
know England as well I what sport do you
go see are you gonna pay money to see
live in person not much anymore but if
anything basketball really but yeah like
the only way I want to go to a game is
if I have like near front row seats
otherwise relatable yeah right yeah are
you taking your girl to two basketball
games is that a good date I haven't been
to a basketball I've been to one this
season but no I don't really go I don't
really go I go to basketball games when
somebody has great tickets and they say
do you want to go what's your ideal date
out there okay
that's like saying what's your favorite
movie what am I in the mood for
ah good date ends with
coming back to the place
when we're not too tired to uh sit on
the couch and watch something okay I
love watching stuff I also hold on press
pause talking about the thing I like to
press pause on Shark Tank
um after an obstacle arises and I like
to do this is how I would handle it um
oh okay I like that and that's a good
way to find out about the other person
how would you handle it
I'm with someone that needs to be um
Escape into the magic of the narrative
you know the problem is you're with
somebody and you think they need to be
different
and that's okay so can we talk a little
bit about I didn't talk about the
roasting that I was interrupted about so
many times let's go if I ever do it it
would have to be first for like I
wouldn't say yes to any person
so if you ever want to ask me I want you
to be able to give me like here are the
three people which one would you be
interested in doing here are three
people to roast which one would you like
to roast yeah
opposed to how uh hey we're doing a
roast of such and such it's like I don't
know
so what is that just the illusion of
choice or no no I might say just try to
create work for me I I might say I'm
saying if you I have to imagine you
usually know a few people depends okay
it depends I guess what I'm saying is if
you ask me and I say no I would still
want you to ask me again
because I'm saying no to the person not
to the idea of doing it copy that okay
and let me ask you something who do you
think would be a good next person to
roast and who would you be interested in
roasting who would I roast I would roast
you okay
it's been done I'm sure round two is a
clamoring for it I would roast any of my
friends yeah and then any of my friends
or anyone that I'm a fan of okay
I like the idea of not needing it to be
Tom Brady or Willie Nelson you know I
would do both Tom Brady and Willie
Nelson yeah like I could do it right now
right okay hey Tom Brady
are you know what I was going to say
something that I would trust on my
podcast to be bleeped and I don't know
if you would so I'm not going to say it
you can just ask me to believe it uh hey
Tom Brady you have five rings cool
you're not a good husband
actually not true I don't know enough
about that I wouldn't say that because
she it seems like that she make him
choose between the two
I don't know man I don't know I just
think you know
you know Tom hey Tom Brady I hate you a
whole bunch and Gisele Bundchen remember
hey the girl from the movie White you
wouldn't make that much money
that's really funny to me just saying
things that are awkward and true hey Tom
Brady
grow up
for real listen man we get it you fixed
your face
but
you know Kobe Bryant said that he played
every single game as best as he could
because he never knew when there was
some poor orphan in the audience for the
first time just there to see Kobe but
whenever you're on the field all you do
is throw laptops and excuses deflategate
you bitch
you Tom Brady
oh Tom Brady yeah
you're so old you might as well be
Willie Nelson thank you guys so much my
name is Rick Glassman make sure you
check out my special the bottom line
where I will be telling people how it is
even if they don't want to hear it
I think I'm built for that Medium
oh then you'd also do stuff where you
say like oh cool cool uh you know uh uh
Bill Mars on the Deus Bill Maher yeah
hey Bill Maher Bill Maher sucks
no but also I'm just joking I I really
am into the bill Marshall and the one
thing I'm missing with this writer
strike is the Bill Marsh show new rules
I love it to be like Bill Maher you're
all over the place politically these
days hey Bill Maher pick a lane yeah
yeah and then we have then we have Julia
Louise Dreyfus next to her and he's like
and you got one right next to you
hey Julie Louise Dreyfus yeah you were
real funny in everything you've ever
done this episode is brought to you by
betterhelp
um so this was a week where I really you
know how like for a lot of people the DJ
Saved their life
you know this week my therapist saved my
life because I
turns out I have something called stored
anger I just don't cry when I need to
cry and I don't know maybe I make jokes
I diffuse whatever I don't know what to
tell you I'm a Showboat
um I use it as engine to perform uh for
drunk people but I have a situation in
my life that is so
um it's like walking on a tightrope
right now like dealing with a person
where there's nothing I can say to them
that they're not going to turn into some
other thing and I've just been
scheduling a session with my therapist
and she said something was so helpful
because I was like I feel kind of like
how crazy am I that I've been going to
like having sessions every week this
week and it's normally not like that
it's one or whatever but it's in crisis
mode and she was like think about it
she's like you know if your relationship
is broken or something's broken you're
gonna go to therapy you know every day
if you have physical therapy like if you
broke your ankle you might need it every
day for a while and then you'll go back
to like once a week or whatever so it's
just like a
I'm very grateful that better help
exists because I would not be going if I
had to get in a car and drive even three
minutes
that is like I can't believe because I
used to always like for therapy where
you'd have to drive it would be like oh
like I would just always cancel because
just the idea of driving was so much
more traumatic than anything that
happened to my childhood
betterhelp.com let therapy be your map
with betterhealth visit betterhelp.com
Whitney get 10 off your first month
that's crazy 10 off your first month you
can switch therapists at any time if you
could switch I would say choose and
switch should I just remixed it into one
word
um and uh that's better help better
help.com you can't lose the only thing
you might lose
are all the narcissists in your life for
the only fans TV roast we did a Premiere
at my house and Rick K which inviting
you was kind of I was like I don't even
know if he's gonna respond to this like
I just had a weird like like inkling
that like Rick is gonna I want Rick in
my life more but I did where did that
come from I ask because that feels nice
to hear well we sort of I didn't know if
you liked me I thought you didn't like
me and um I was just kind of like oh
every time I see him I like him and I
always feel like we have good
conversations but I feel like we just I
did see you a couple times I know we
don't you said we don't see each other
much I had to see a couple times at The
Improv right um right before you texted
yeah totally and I was like I think we
get along or like I don't know like I'd
like him whatever like why not then you
showed up and you were like the life of
the party and it was so magical to watch
there were so many comics in their own
little groups or I will refer to as a
lot of different stages and I was stoned
and I came by myself and there's an
energy that you have when I love going
to the movies by myself especially
during the day come walking out of a
movie it's still daylight look what I
feel like I accomplished something look
what I accomplished saw a movie it's
still daytime
and when I'm by myself there's there's
this feeling of like
this is corny and I'm I subscribe to it
100 I sometimes tap into being my best
friend and I love that like loving
myself and in in a way to where like
I sometimes even talk to myself dude I
I'm sorry I don't interrupt but I'm so
into this um when I'm by myself
especially when I'm high like I talked
about before where like you have that
thing that this hack into we're having
fun who's we come on this is we're
awesome yeah and I had this thing and I
got to go into groups and I got to do
bits and when it was working you wrote
it if if I wasn't feeling it or I felt
like they weren't you'd be like okay no
I don't want to linger you go to the
next one and you just and then you get
to do all these you're juggling all
these balls and I remember all the bits
at all the stages so then when you get
to come back to another stage it's like
is your sister is your sister better or
whatever the thing is and then it's like
all right we're back or we're not and if
you fail it's it's like 30 Rock or
Family Guy I feel like Theory right on
Family Guy they have so many jokes that
when something misses maybe you notice
but it doesn't ruin the momentum at all
it doesn't matter that one didn't work
and let's just keep doing it because
it's a joke machine the problem with
being in one group as a joke machine is
does this guy ever turn it off sometimes
but when you get to leave you get to
stay on and you get to let shit breathe
oh but but I love this because you kind
of I do this in my life in a dramatic
way but not in a comedy way that you
kind of are like in a weird way this is
what I'm hearing as you approach a
situation that might normally be anxiety
inducing or you know disorienting or
high pressure situation and you kind of
turn into a TV show you're like what
show am I in right now I'm in New Girl
and I'm going to be the Max Greenfield
character I'm in Family Guy and I'm
going to be that's going to be the
Lemoine character sure sorry I just I'm
a little more perfect thank you and so
um the same way that when I'm in a
situation where I don't know what to do
I will go if I was in a drama or if I
was in like a romance comedy what would
the hero do right now because I don't
know what to do I'm a hero interesting I
always go what would the best friend
next door do or that what like what
would the person do to get the guy back
what would the girl say I just need to
go say I'm sorry and I need to kiss him
on the mouth and ideally it's raining
but I'm gonna figure this out you know
like I will just go what movie am I in
and just be that person so I have this
and this is just one I'm on which is a
lot of the time
I see the world
uh I don't mean this in a spiritual way
I just mean like oh this is why when
I've disconnected it's because people
don't see it this way
there's always a camera on me
always and when I do something I also
people like oh Rick you like to make
people uncomfortable or you like to make
things weird I want everybody to know
everything I'm doing when people would
compare some of the stuff I do to Andy
Kaufman who was great he got off on them
not getting it I want everybody to get
it but I'm not affected negatively when
they don't because that's just a product
of committing to something and they get
to feel weird or uncomfortable or left
and then they'll figure it out but like
yes they do that's a feeling too but
when I'm on stage I have learned and it
took me a while to figure this out I do
need to make sure they're in on it
because it was really tough to do this
thing that I was doing but if I I didn't
want to wink to them because then I want
them to feel it's real just no it's not
and I've learned how to do that by doing
certain types of jokes up top I like
that you build tension and you play to
the top of people it's intelligence do
love it love it so much also then when
I'm uncomfortable or if I'm in a
situation where I recognize oh I'm late
to understanding that they don't want
this which I don't want to be yeah but I
will be
oh I get to see that with this person
okay and it makes it just like
it's funny yeah so much is funny so this
is to me like what I'm hearing is this
is how you win at life and every moment
that could be embarrassing or
humiliating or uncomfortable or cringy
you're just gonna try it by going like
I'm joking here like I'm just gonna make
this fun kinda I won't let you make this
um suck I know I'm a devil that I play
Devil's Advocate I know you called me
out but I want this is I have strong
opinions because I try to do that
sometimes where I go you know I'm gonna
go in here and I'm gonna make fun of
myself and I'm gonna make this fun uh at
all costs I'm gonna lead with joy and if
someone tries to bring me down I'm just
gonna go like all right well I'm moving
on to this person I'm gonna find who
does get me and who does vibrate on my
frequency definitely to the end of it
find the people who vibrate on your
frequency
um that I'm just gonna do this despite
makes me sound like when people say like
I don't care what other people think
it's more like when you go to something
an event like that a party for only fans
TV that's a roast and you walk into a
conversation and everyone's like what's
up and they're like anyway so I hear
Trump is running again and can you
believe that he had the documents at
home and you're like oh whoa I'm out can
I you know I actually think it's cool
that he brings his work home that
probably means he works hard and you're
doing the what I'm and then everyone's
like uh and you're like I'm joking you
guys are seriously having this
conversation okay may I please okay I'm
gonna be I'm gonna be really forcing my
point of view here great and I don't I
don't know if we're disagreeing agreeing
or just saying I'm agreeing on something
similarly I agree with someone some of
them I disagree with and I wanna I wanna
break it down with the thing that I
disagree with
okay okay because I think I'm just
trying to understand what you're saying
yeah so when you go into the Trump thing
and they're talking about the Trump
thing and your feeling is are we really
talking about this I'm going to reflect
this yeah why do this now yeah that's
where I disagree because that's what
they want to talk about and I I I
understand this is just a silly example
but
if I go in and they're talking about the
Trump stuff I might do a bit and see if
that plays I might not but I'm going to
be a little bit more sensitive to
oh
I don't this isn't for me or this is
what I would do so if I would
um walk into a situation like that
that's a we're having fun we're out
because to me if you're talking about
Trump or Politics on a Saturday at a fun
event you're an ad never on a Saturday
and never had a funny addict you're
addicted to self-righteous in a nation
you're addicted to politics you're like
you're addicted to talking about this
thing well have you ever seen Bill Maher
new rules uh well that's great we can
come back to that in a second because
you do really want to talk about it and
um uh I he has a podcast too now but
that's different yeah I haven't watched
this podcast but I love new rules we've
always been a big fan and so um going
into you know when I walk into a bunch
of people then what are you guys talking
about oh and then Trump did this and
then and I'm like oh did you guys solve
did you fix it um like is this oh are we
fixing but if you do that and then they
play back sure but if they go like
winning yeah people literally I'm an
alt-right Maga person because I won't
have serious intense conversations about
politics on a Saturday night at like an
event I'm like you guys let's just do
you know enough about stuff to have
serious conversations I would know of
course again I just don't I just think
context is everything and I think that
we're comedian it's our job to know uh
when someone wants someone wants your
something
and my job is just like to bring levity
and I do that off camera too or not when
I'm not working and if someone's gonna
want to have a serious conversation
about politics like while there's four
glasses of wine in like none of this is
getting solved here we're having a
serious conversation about communication
people are going to be like
self-righteous who cares I'm not the fun
person in politics I'm like you guys you
know that none of this matters until we
get rid of the Electoral College and the
Supreme Court so nobody knows what that
means Whitney
you just said
you're just unnecessarily adrenalizing
everybody and bumming everybody out for
no reason okay you don't think I could
talk to you about the Electoral College
and teach the audience but also have you
entertained but until voting isn't on a
weekday none of what you're saying is
even possible so I do want to make sure
we don't step on this it's so important
to vote I'm just saying for me I cannot
take a conversation like that seriously
because I'm like you guys just seem
ridiculous that you're like let's talk
about Trump's documents let's talk about
the voting stuff anymore I know but
that's what I do when I come into
pronounce but now you're forcing it on
me
and the idea about me talking about is
important to vote sure but I was joking
about that strong point of view do what
you want I'm just saying this is what
comedians sometimes I don't want to talk
about that part anymore I know we're
similar in that way well then stop this
is this is why we're similar and this is
why a lot of my friendships are stressed
because everyone just wants to talk
about politics and I'm like everybody
doesn't want to talk about politics some
people talk about politics sometimes we
get to hang out with comics and I think
you're doing it you're finding a way to
talk about politics well the person
opposite you is saying I don't want to
do it and you're still doing it continue
politics dude I gotta do say though did
you see what happened with Biden
recently and Kamala Harris with the
thing
fucking and the way he speaks
it's insane man boring always boring
guys I'm supporting your points
no you weren't you were talking about my
point and then talking about getting a
little circuitous there and I'm trying I
don't know whatever one out of every 200
words you say I don't know what they
mean that's not true what does
circuitous mean means like it was taking
a serpentine Road
you have so many big words go okay so
we're basically saying
to buy products
that's a goal okay okay I it's as simple
as this I'm a little boy looking for
somebody to play with and I've sometimes
I gotta play with myself yeah sometimes
I touch myself like I'm saying like I
masturbate are you do you watch porn
um not as much as I could
believe me I could watch a lot more do
you try to restrain yourself a little
bit it seems like it seems like we're
going towards that a guy seemed to be
trying to watch less yeah a lot less
different kinds or less hardcore kind oh
no I watch it all the time I'm just
trying to pick two genres or just less
frequency less frequency like I'm only
gonna watch missionary instead of
gangbang nobody is ever trying to only
not to knock missionary one of my best
friends is black but what I'm saying is
people try and nobody tries and just
watches missionary that's a silly silly
example you know what I mean I'm saying
like you want like maybe watching less
hardcore
or are you just watching less of the
hardcore I am watching less pornography
in general and as Riley Reid would say
pun intended period
so what does that look like when you go
to log into pornhub or gerbil what is it
gerbil.com what is it sex durable what
was the one there was another one uh
poop hamster ass gerbil yeah there's a
yeah acting like you don't know what it
is it's on your favorites no there's one
that who was it the fart porn that Greg
Simmons told us about xxhamster
I cannot stand it when a podcaster is
like what's the thing called what's it
called again is it called This is it
called this and then you know and I'm
like what's it called you guys have to
Whitney this is my half
if I want us to go forward
that's what we'll do go on ask your
question I cannot believe audio and you
slam my half that is my
um is it OCD Asperger's or whatever
what's your dog's name again beef is
that your pet I love it when someone
looks up the ceiling you know it's funny
that you love that now when it's not
involving a a fake relationship because
when I was trying to be communicative
with you before about getting home at
three I look away and immediately you
think I'm cheating on you I just think
that people don't realize how obvious
obvious it is when they're lying or
making something up or when like I do
this my guy all the time when he'll I'll
say something and he'll like look away
when he's saying something and I'm like
dude do you not think I see you there
are so many factors to that that unless
you're trained for example dude I will
not break eye contact to save anyone's
life yeah and you gotta study how to do
it that's true not everybody lives their
life from overcompensating but I'm not
out here talking to people ask me a
question I'm not looking up and looking
back and then trying to Gaslight the
other person to be like what I didn't
look away I'm like I just saw you look
away what if you ask me a question okay
you get it so far yeah you've asked me
four and you answered three of them what
if you asked me a question cold open
what if you ask me a question and the
question you asked me was about the
roasts that you made okay okay and asked
me if I liked it
and let's say I thought it was okay okay
and I'm a little uncomfortable with how
to answer this so I'm gonna take my time
I'm gonna choose my words even more
intentionally I would say just pick what
you don't know what you would say I'm
gonna tell you I'm telling you I'm just
telling you how to respond to give
someone feedback on something you don't
like without having to lie I'm telling
you
humans operate in many different ways
and you have to either accept that they
do that or try and control it and be
hurt and anxious
done with what I would say I know let me
say it let me say it
you're so you're so confident on how I'm
supposed to say stuff you don't even let
me do it no I'm trying you know what
maybe put that tiger back in the cage
for five years I'm trying to get an
example in here I'm trying to get an
example in here let's go you're you're
taking it it's 145.
if I don't know how I want to answer
because I have my own ways of feeling
safe I have my own ways of communication
I have my own ways of getting out my
truth which I always find a way to do
so if you were to ask me how I felt
about it it all depends on what's our
Dynamic what have we been busting balls
or is this is she feeling a little
insecure at this moment I don't know I
felt like people weren't having a good
time did you have a good time and I
wanted to corroborate your you have to
feel that out and there's different ways
of doing that and with that comes
empathy empathizing that there are
things you may be more sensitive to like
when you get high it doesn't mean lie to
you it just means empathize and with
empathy comes that feeling so if I am
feeling you feeling uncomfortable or
unsure I may start to I will start
taking that on I'm not going to take
that on as my responsibility but to
pretend that I don't is lying to both of
us so when you ask me a question and I'm
a little uncomfortable I might look away
or I might
swallow or take my time or stall or ask
a follow question before getting to
I
because I know how funny you are I can
say this wasn't the best thing you know
there's ways of doing it where you're
not lying but you're being empathetic to
the person so if I'm uncomfortable what
would men lecture women on how emotions
work this is one of my favorites and I'm
not going to say women because I tries
to find a way to justify lying that's
literally what I mean I'm so fucking
it's you know what I I I I I see this
first of all I'm not men I'm Rick
okay okay all right I had to pee twice
that's true
but I do think oh was I saying first of
all because there was only one
and B okay I'm not justifying to you how
emotions work I am quite literally
telling you how I would feel right how I
would feel if you're vulnerable and in
asking for feedback on some a project
I'm just saying if you don't get rid of
your just I'm just like looking away is
usually means there's a lie coming and
there's always a way if someone says do
I look pretty in this outfit and there's
always so ask me if a comedian was funny
last night was such and such funny last
night he's such a nice guy his stage
presence is amazing cool man well I can
say something that is true okay cool but
don't complain about how you're being
received a certain way while you don't
value tact if you're saying people see
me as this aggressive person but fuck
that I tell people when they suck maybe
take a beat look away and empathize a
little bit it's not lying it's not lying
to realize I need to deliver this a
certain way as long as you deliver it
there's there's so many different ways
of telling people stuff I do like when
people are direct so incidentally if I
were to say how is the set you go well
Rick you're normally funny I like you
would be like you don't you don't need
to do that but it's not about you
it's not about me it's about the person
who's saying the thing
so when we know each other well enough
we could have that shorthand but if we
don't
and I'm uncomfortable I'm also aware of
that to where she's now I'm going to be
thinking she's gonna think if I look
away I have to lie so I'm going to be
here staring at her but what I'm really
doing is now in my head thinking about
what she needs for me to be authentic
and I'm not present anymore that's not a
place to live
looking away means thought it doesn't
mean lying
everybody sometimes I I think that this
is there we go this is the one thing
that I think is missing from all this is
just you your gut instinct so if someone
goes like where were you until three in
the morning uh I was why can't you just
look me in the eye and say it to me I I
boil people down between people who can
look you in the eye and people who can't
I have I hear you and if you can't look
me in the eye when you're talking to me
I don't trust you says the person who's
been looking in the eyes for six years
no even before that even when I thought
I was looking people in the eye I was
missing you're missing
a robot and I get this because I'm the
same way robot well you're not
understanding is people might be afraid
of you based on the way that you have
responded to them you might be afraid of
me
don't have your shit away
maybe that wasn't dishonest wait did
that look away was that no that was fine
you know the difference and you know you
know well what I was doing before at the
beginning that look away yeah I was in
in my first of all it's an improvement
yeah but you had you were thinking of
whatever you were thinking about all of
this is an improv game hey Whitney life
is an improv game I think that's that's
one of the saddest things I've ever
heard why anyone say why like that is
devastating life is an improv game but I
I will die on this hill when someone is
talking to you and like ask me anything
when I was talking to you you were
looking at your laptop well yeah that
was different that was conscious oh I'm
saying when someone's looking at you and
it's like the other day I was going down
what if they're bored that's fine too
but you know the difference you that I
would say oh you're looking away because
you're bored to be honest with you but
if the pressure is on with somebody and
they're like yeah well I just I decided
to stop at my friend's house I look away
when I'm thinking
and thinking doesn't mean manufacturing
it but why are you thinking about your
answer you should know the answer you
don't even have to think about it and
that's what you're not connecting with
or should I say not anything to me about
it and we're I I'm talking about a one
what am I not believing you about Rick
what are you talking about Rick we've
never had this conversation in this
fight we've never been under true
pressure where I'm going hey where were
you until three in the morning and
you've actually done well let's come up
with an example that isn't about a a
monogamous relationship because you and
I are not in there let's have a real one
do you want to hire Jenny Molasky to run
the sitcom
listen I think she's funny okay the
answer is no no I'm joking I don't know
who that is right I made I made up a
name that was not a lie to me that was
uh I already I let me figure out a way
to say this in a gentle way
that's always you didn't do this you
didn't do this well no so ask me do you
want Johnny mullaney to be your
showrunner yeah
yeah my name is Rick how'd you know
because that's like no because that was
the game that was established
because that's what you did to me so I'm
showing you what it would look like when
someone is lying well thanks for having
a interesting having a woman showing a
man what something looks like
you know you here's here's here's the
trauma speaking here's your here's I
will diagnose you here's your trauma
speaking please you will fill in the
blank of other people's stalling or
thinking to mean that must be a lie as
opposed to they're trying to find their
safe space to think about something
that's just a fact because because not
everybody knows the thing right away and
I'm speaking from somebody who's
probably the quickest person you've ever
met yeah so you don't know where you
were until three in the morning you have
to think about it
that's the point I'm making okay I'm not
saying what's your opinion on this can
we cut back to that thing because that
thing was
me realizing you're right
I
okay so it might be part of me that's
like I'm I'm an autonomous person I know
I didn't do anything wrong I'm allowed
to agree but no hold on you're yeah I
concede I had to have that thought yeah
what you're saying makes sense listen if
I'm asking for your opinion you have all
the time to look around and think about
it I need you to ask for my opinion I
could always offer it what kind of car
to your drive
an Audi you did that on purpose did what
on purpose I don't think you I think I
don't think you normally would have done
that you have I have known you maybe
you're right you have never looked away
from I don't think we've ever broken eye
contact when we've talked about I don't
feel that there is any sense of
of
um how uh uncertainty with how you will
respond to my car so the stakes are low
but if you ask me something for example
about another comedian something even
off camera because I would not here
one of two things will happen yeah one
of three things will happen I'm not
perfect and I might go into it I I hate
it I don't like talking about other
people and I I me either and I will
honestly say that uh uh
doesn't matter so the two the two things
are either
establishing the boundary right away
which is hey Winnie I don't like talking
about other Comics it doesn't make me
feel good which I have said and can say
or there might be something if there's a
lot of people and it feels like I'm
forcing an agenda I'm like Rick's
shutting it down I could just leave yeah
yeah where if it's brought up to me
I might be a little uncomfortable how
are they going to receive me are they
going to think
what are they gonna think now the truth
is it doesn't matter I don't control
that but I'm not as perfectly
enlightened person I know odd so I'm
going to have some thoughts and some
concerns or some uncertainty and it
matters so if you ask me how I feel
about another person me looking away
doesn't mean I'm necessarily going to be
lying about them I'm I'm like not even
thinking about what to say about them
I'm thinking how do I get out of this
but this is I I need you to hear what
I'm saying I'm not saying this is the
case when you're asking someone's
opinion it's when you're asking a fact
something that's not negotiable and not
an opinion so what is Sebastian's life
okay let me great Maniscalco great if
you looked away do this with me with
another fact I'm not saying what do you
how do you feel about Sebastian
Maniscalco I'm saying what's Sebastian's
last name okay Maniscalco there's no
need to really look away how do you feel
about him
um that that makes sense I don't know
what I want to say sure so looking away
is okay for an opinion not for fact
that's your rule yes or that's just
usually when it's like when you're
asking someone uh uh something that just
should be an irrefutable black and white
fact and they look where were you I
think they're making something out that
might help I think I'm leaving something
out because you have such a strong
opinion on this that I've been fighting
this other side also I absolutely agree
with you
people do that people could have people
have tells people will be like 100 I
don't like when somebody does some shit
like that and then tries to Gaslight you
into being like no I didn't look away no
I'm just thinking it's like you had to
say you're accusing this is where
because I'm only fighting the other side
because you you you're giving no
attention to it because they both exist
you were which I've said many times
well you said what many times I'm saying
if it's an irrefutable fact it would be
unlikely that you would need to here's
an ear I went to Whitney's party okay
now let's say we have a mutual friend
and you didn't invite that friend yeah
and that friend didn't know I went to
Whitney's party that friend wanted to go
to Whitney's party and I know that and I
know that person is a little insecure
about their relationship with you sure
and they say hey did you go to Whitney's
party I will probably not right away be
like yep and just that's their feelings
they could deal it I will probably look
away look away collect my thoughts and
in that moment knowing me of being
present I would probably end up finding
a way of going okay I'm looking away
here's why or I might be looking away
and actually trying to either figure out
how to say it or realistically
um though I might be becoming aware of
my projections of how they might receive
it mm-hmm
what do I want to say
before ultimately getting to the thing
where I'm not gonna say no but I'm gonna
need to think about it and knowing that
this person if I look away now they're
going to think I'm lying and I looked
away because that's my natural instinct
yeah and now I'm gonna be like I looked
away it wasn't because of that why being
so defensive now and it's a lose-lose
because you are so sure yeah about the
other person and here's a problem here's
a big problem when somebody tells you
what they think and what they believe
you could not believe them but then it's
just not going to work you don't trust
that person maybe they didn't earn your
trust maybe you have trust trauma
whatever and they're not mutually
exclusive but it is not my job to
convince you to trust me I'm a
trustworthy person and if you don't
trust me that's a bummer and we could
have these conversations you're talking
to Whitney are you talking to just
people I'm talking I'm talking to what
you right now because in that moment I
go if I go did you go to Whitney's party
and you go yes I'm I don't think you're
lying but I go is there something weird
but I'm saying before I say yes I'm very
into micro expressions and I think that
a lot of times you just told me you
couldn't read them and now you you're
into the micro once I'm saying I think
well I live in LA a lot of Botox but it
there's you're making a joke about a
real contradiction though but I'm saying
I think a lot of time people don't know
what they're doing with their eyes and
my brain goes not of course they don't
know they also don't know how they're
actually feeling and I'm not accusing
you of lying I'm just saying I saw that
don't pretend it didn't happen there was
something there and just go yeah I I
died and now and now I would go yeah I
didn't know if you were invited I feel
bad but now you're making it about the
way the person is and the way they
looked as opposed to just the thing that
is where the line is
and we could we could fight about
multiple things let's do I don't know
why you're fighting me this has gotten
too intense in my opinion for what I'm
for what I'm trying to for what I'm
trying to say which is just in my
experience if someone if I'm asking
someone a fact just a yes or no question
where would go three in the morning and
they have to do that
I believe something shady is going on I
don't have to say you're lying I'm
saying like is there a reason you don't
feel like you can tell me this should I
not have asked that question wait I just
said fighting I meant like if we were
fighting I didn't realize that we were
fighting I thought I was just we were
just like under something yeah I'm
saying like if we're fighting like like
in these things where you think I'm
lying to you in a fight but we were
joking all of it was a joke
oh I wasn't uh uh I I want to do more of
this but it seems like that's not what
we're doing no I I don't know I don't
know where to
where to where to to to perhaps
acknowledge or at least for me to
acknowledge that just because and I
don't I don't really think I'm making
this up when someone is telling you a
lie they will often find it difficult to
look you directly they often fight wait
wait wait wait what's that word they
will what when someone is telling you
it's just that one word they when
someone is telling you a lie they will
often find it difficult that's all I'm
arguing sure often doesn't mean that's
what it is fair but when you're that
sure about it and yeah that does
honestly if you couldn't tell that does
trigger me because I can't tell because
I can't tell I'm not lying to you
and I don't think you are and I'm with
you on this because I have had really
intense trouble in the past and I think
now I really pride myself on being able
to make eye contact and not go like yeah
here's what and worry about what
someone's gonna think like I think we're
very similar in that way but for me I do
have to kind of because I do have in the
past have a really hard time
understanding people and can't tell when
people are lying to me that I do
sometimes have to just go like if I'm
asking a yes or no question people could
still be lying to you even if they're
able to look you right in the eyes 100
probably more so than the person who's
empathizing but 100 so but for me I
think I've just sometimes have to find
these like okay the common denominator
here is every time I ask a question
they're like doing this and I go
I need to take that into consideration
if it asks them if it corroborates with
my gut if I feel I'm being lied okay
because there are times someone can look
me in the face and say something I go oh
this person's looking me in the eye and
lying to my face I don't have good
instincts for that I ask a lot of
questions I don't think I have a good
like I even said before I've always just
why would they be lying right but I hear
you but but I think that I'm the first
to say like that person looked me right
in the eye and lied to me to my face I
say that a lot too but I it but and we
started this I actually was kind of
being facetious also when we were doing
the Improv because you like looked up
and I was like oh why are you looking
over there
within the Improv yes you know what I
mean so I was kind of like oh that would
just be a funny thing to say in the
Improv but I do think I find myself a
lot of times when I'm asking someone a
yes or no question or a very simple
question and they're like oh well uh
yeah people people need to find their
safe space and sometimes a direct
question can make them uncomfortable
yeah that's true so let them have their
moment to figure it out
cold open
I get it
this seems like very upsetting to you
and I'm not trying to upset you or
attack you I don't feel upset I didn't
even I didn't even recognize that it was
like
um what I guess you were feeling as
contentious maybe until you call that
out and I'll go like oh yeah yeah you're
right like to me I I it just felt like
playing basketball like no no no no I
just felt like debating sides but you're
right totally I I just I didn't know if
I walked into like a hornet's Nets or
something because for me I'm I I'm the
first to say that guy looked me in the
eye and lied to my face so here's the
the thing that is triggering is not
specifically about the lying it's
somebody knowing something when they
can't you don't know what I'm thinking
yeah your observation is fair call me
out ask me but then listen there's also
like this other this in between that I
think is like you know we're also we
live in a business not that there aren't
many other business that have the skill
of like were we are we're amongst actors
you know what I mean that we live you
know I'm a lot of times doing business
with people sure when prizes like what
they said about Robin Williams and and
Missed Out Fire they're like he's such
it's a great great show of dad but
because you're an actor I think you're
acting you're not really a good dad oh
interesting and I'm like no
there's just times that I'll be in
business with certain people and I'm
just like oh you win awards for lying I
win awards for being an actor yep as a
dramatic one doesn't mean I'm not
hysterical 100 and like for me I
sometimes so overcompensate if I'm being
insincere about something I'll out
myself sometimes I'll double down on the
eye contact and be like I loved it it
was the your movie was perfect sometimes
when someone says how you doing you have
to just say good thanks how are you
right even if it feels disingenuous I
mean I just because I know that if I go
I loved your movie it was like so good I
that they're gonna think I'm lying and I
know in this moment they need me to just
say the thing that they need to hear so
I'm probably I'm guilty of lying to
someone's face I've done it but I think
that the one thing we're missing is when
you feel like someone's lying to you
I've spent my whole life being like no I
must be wrong no okay and it sometimes
helps me to go like yeah that was a lie
and then
you just lied to my face it's fine I'll
get over it but like why what can I do
to make it so you don't feel like you
have to lie uh that's a good question
like because I don't like calling people
out no but that's a great question what
can do you need a minute am I attacking
you am I being too aggressive you don't
give them don't even give them a
multiple choice are my arms doing this
like am I does it seem like I'm yelling
am I recreating your childhood
circumstances they might be able to then
tell you I don't feel safe being
completely disarmed and vulnerable with
you right and then you get to say why
right and now they'll probably look away
and take a moment
to tell you some of it right and feel it
is there shame here is there
embarrassment it might just be the way
you receive them right you might I'll
tell you why Whitney because whenever we
talk about something vulnerable you yell
at me for looking away and now I feel
like I don't know what I'm supposed to
do now you're trying so hard not to look
away I look away yeah you know like I
find myself doing that sometimes you
know but I think for me recently I have
like a couple relationships where when
things get tense or you know I just want
to get to the bottom that I'm truly in a
couple like relationships friendships
where like I want to grow and do the
like hard Communications and I I'm like
and then I'm like you know when this
happened the other day were you upset at
me and they're like well no and I'm like
but I think you were and you're not
telling me are you sure because I might
triggered because here's the trigger but
here's the thing my gut feels you are
and then when I ask you about it you
look away are you just trying to make
this go away and if so just say that
just go like now to you it's not up to
you when they're ready to tell you their
truth but then I go do you want to tell
me when you're ready and we'll talk then
yeah maybe but are you are you open to
listening to how I'll be ready
sure
great just if you lie to me then then
I'm in my trigger to I was lied to my
whole life hey man human interaction's
tough I agree and then I'm going if
you're lying to me how can we ever get
to the bottom of this so you tell me
when you're ready to tell the truth
about it all right here here it is or we
can do it over text I'll tell you right
now do it over letters I'll tell you
right now I feel and this is just a
feeling
when we're having serious conversations
I feel a little controlled and I feel
like I have to tell you a thing the way
you want me to tell it and yeah I'll
admit that sometimes I kind of omit
things or wait to tell you until a
different time I could have told you
today but I was probably waiting till it
I was planning on telling you I just
feel a little uncomfortable telling you
things and what you're hearing is that
you're worried that there's going to be
like a negative consequence if you tell
me the truth yeah or you're going to
tell me that what I'm saying I'm lying
to you or you're gonna you're gonna pass
judgment on me or we're gonna get into a
fight or we're gonna have to have a
three-hour conversation that's draining
It's just sometimes it doesn't feel
worth it just to be honest
acting by the way uh and then I go like
but are you lying I guess to me I yeah
yes I didn't feel comfortable telling
you this yet but yes I I uh
I didn't go to your party because I I
wasn't really busy I didn't want to go
and I could have told no one's ever
wanted to go to a party so I knew that
I'm glad you received me well on that I
was scared because XYZ happened in the
past see I have oxygen in my lungs as
soon as someone says the thing that they
think they can't say same I can breathe
so someone goes you know what I didn't
tell you the truth because I was worried
you were gonna fly off the handle
because that time and at Hanukkah you
did that and I'm worried that you have a
the worst thing you could possibly say
to me saying it is the only time I feel
safe is when someone says the ugliest
thing they could possibly say that's not
an ugly thing they're just telling you
their feelings an ugly thing is judging
you for it but when someone's like yeah
no um I had a great time and you're like
why is your voice going up and your eyes
going up there and to me because it also
the subtext is you're so dumb you're
gonna fall for this nope I'm just
telling you that's the subtext of like
do you really think so now and then the
pressure of now I have to enter into
your hey man your lie don't say that
you're not a great story writer because
you're writing a whole whole story about
things that doesn't happen oh when
someone lies your face I I'm like so now
I have to go totally cool now I'm just
gonna pretend I believe this you know I
don't I know you're lying and we're just
both gonna pretend it's it's it's just a
more it's just a more intimate version
of how you doing
just but these are more high stakes
things I just I just mean once there's a
lie I guess to me it's like and maybe
it's like an OCD thing maybe it's a
whatever Spectrum thing I'm happy to be
wrong but once there's like a lie it
like it cuts this little thing where I'm
kind of like
it it's insulting because you're saying
you can't handle the truth you're too
weak or you're too fragile and then I'm
like oh you're calling me weak and
fragile right and that to me feels like
a little bit disrespectful and or or uh
uh uh I'm gonna lie to you and Look Away
really quick ask me anything how's your
day
um it was good
I don't know why I just did that that
was weird I like I just didn't know the
answer
I think that lying is uh depends on what
it is and if you're hurting somebody
yeah but lying and people pleasing come
from a similar place which is
um it is yes it's a selfish act but it's
not because of Any judgment they have on
the other person it's because if I don't
please Whitney I'm not gonna like the
way I feel with her judgment toward me
I'm not doing it to make Whitney happy
I'm doing it so I don't get
uncomfortable it's the same with a lie
I'm not lying to Whitney because I think
she's weak I'm lying to Whitney because
it'll make me feel more comfortable not
having to deal with if I hurt somebody's
feelings I don't want to feel like a bad
person I don't want to feel like I told
this person at the wrong time I don't
want to tell them like I didn't
empathize with how to tell this person
but then that's that's selfish because
you're trying to avoid a feeling
absolutely but the truth is and that's
why I'm playing Devil's Advocate because
I'm more so on your side but the thing
that I have learned and is why I'm
preaching at this point is
just because we think this way doesn't
mean these people do sure and there are
ways for them to tell you things that
our directness might cannibalize I'm I
and I know and like I've struggled with
this my whole life of going like just
tell me the truth like I can handle it I
I'm a big girl have you ever told
somebody the truth and they couldn't
handle it yes right those people
probably don't speak the same way you do
that's not my responsibility because I
like no it's not because then I'm just
patronizing you and I'm gonna insult you
more and how are you having to learn to
handle the truth it's not your walk on
eggshells and patronize you all the time
like I'm not going to enable that either
I don't want to be a partner it's not
about taking responsibility it's just
about acknowledging the truth of human
connection these people are this way
yeah some people have to pee a lot and
I'm only talking about close
relationships where you're just like you
think I don't know you well enough to
know the difference when you're telling
the truth when you're lying and you're
just it's kind of to me just a little
bit like hey I'm just gonna call you
dumb today and then I have to go like
will you just like yeah I guess it
depends on the stakes but I think so in
close relationships it's important to be
able to have those conversations of hey
I don't feel safe
I'm not ready to answer this question at
the moment yeah that one I like I'm not
sure why I'm hungry angry lonely tired
you know what I need to take a big four
what's that yeah the big four like you
know what I'm not ready to have this
conversation yet do you mind if I take a
walk first you know what I'm feeling
pressure and I'm feeling weird like
energy from you do you mind if I take a
second love it take a second I feel I'm
feeling uncomfortable I need to like
regroup love a regroup you know what I
mean like I'm feeling feelings come up
that may be about you may not be about
you might be hysterical it might be
historical or it might be you I feel
like you need an answer hysterical or
historical or you also good merch like
like I I feel like I feel controlled or
I feel like pressure to answer this
perfectly can I have a second and
they're like oh my God let me take the
pressure off you I'm so sorry I was just
like I didn't realize I was doing that
you said this before so I don't want to
take take this away that you were the
first one to say it but I wanna my blood
sugar is getting a little low and I
don't want to end it with that so I
think let's find
what did it say Hollywood baby let's
find a couple minutes of doing something
fun
that was pretty fun
pretty intense look how much I drank but
I when I do you hear about the uh the
Native American who walked into a
therapist's office because he couldn't
sleep and the therapist said relax your
wigwam
hahaha
I we learned a lot of our triggers when
I feel like I'm not being clear about
what I'm trying to say I feel like I'm
um like in a glass box and I and like
the sound isn't coming out right and if
I'm upsetting someone by accident
because I'm just like if I just said
this one thing I think you would realize
we're actually agreeing on this fair I
agree with almost all of what you said
really it just was I didn't like the
certainty in which you said it
interesting I didn't like the the like
now I know what you're thinking if if
you don't know what someone's thinking I
don't know is anyone thinking I just go
like because intention and impact are
different and I go the impact of that is
that is what that seemed like to me
that's different I should have said
seemed like would have loved us if you
said seemed like we would have been done
20 minutes
and I think one thing I will say though
or even better than that felt like and
this is a trick because once when you do
say why did you just do that you're
lying and someone gets defensive that's
usually the thing that kind of like
because if someone says if I said to you
right now you're lying you'd be like
what and then I go okay he's not depends
on the situation yeah depends on the
relationship if you keep calling me a
liar
and and you say that you didn't drink
four Waters and there's four right there
yeah I would be like what the fuck are
you talking about
one
one three four oh you know what you're
right this
is
sorry I lied I'm just me like then why
are we even talking you might be the
only person more literal than me that
I've ever met this is how all male
comedians are with me so I'm kind of
just how am I well we I said it when I
started your pockets I was like why
everyone's feeling very combative with
me recently on podcasts and I'm not sure
Whitney Schultz's podcast he wanted to
fight with me on a podcast I just feel
like there's maybe a thing where people
want to fight me recently I don't think
that we fought and at all but if at
anything it would be the very end of the
podcast and maybe some people feel that
way because they're combative and they
have their own issues and
perhaps when somebody is so sure about
something that they can't be sure about
sure and somebody opposite them has a
strong opinion against that certainty
yeah this is gonna happen yeah now had
you said it seemed like or even better
felt like I don't think that would have
happened
but now a mansplaining and for that I'm
sorry I think that women
need to be uh
they need to choose their words
carefully I think they need to stop
saying sorry and start saying excuse me
because it wasn't your fault you could
acknowledge being bumped into or bumping
into somebody else without submitting to
them yeah and I think we grow up in a
culture where women are supposed to just
be so yes yes and do and make happy and
don't show don't you know be a good girl
that they don't get to grow up and be a
strong Confident Woman despite what you
feel about yourself that you're fine
just kidding how is it possibly
confident in a world where a guy just
you know like you know what I mean you
are confident you know what I mean
what do you mean I know what you mean I
feel like this whole conversation like I
feel like you know what I mean but this
thing when someone is just like yeah but
this is what you said it's like but you
know what I meant that's fair I didn't
realize if I was doing that then okay
you know what I meant like you know that
I wouldn't wanted this to have happened
like you know we agree on more than we
don't like you know yeah but
I am being a little offensive but didn't
I say throughout I do agree with you I'm
just playing the other side because
you're not yes yes yes yes that's what
we do that's what that's what we do here
as Comics okay so what's happening now
is this is all stuff that
um thankfully is at the end of the
podcast but this is all stuff that you
don't need to take any of it out but
it's like okay but I also feel like now
is one of our first real conversations
and that's a big plus to me with
podcasting ditto I'm already reading the
comments from the last 40 minutes of
this podcast be as judgmental as you
want this is one this we captured a
couple of hours on a certain day at
least we weren't spending a Saturday
afternoon at a party talking about
fucking trump it is what it is and we
talk about this kind of stuff I like
talking about this kind of stuff get off
my ass
well I hope um I I don't know I I have
fun with you I like I like people that
it doesn't matter where you are you're
just where you are and you're not
pretending something's not happening
yeah you know what I'm saying so it's
like if I said something was triggering
to you and that's what happened like
that's what happened yeah and I think a
lot of people will get a lot of out of
that
I did we'll see I just went bitch when
you talk be more clear be more specific
and if you see things going off the
rails be like I'm sorry I must not have
been clear I apologize but in a podcast
table confidence
I don't think to do that and I and I was
so uh post game Wrap Up
um uh outro of interrupting you that I
didn't go you know what I'm so sorry to
do this but I am worried that I wasn't
clear in what I said say it say it again
then differently that's my favorite
thing that you do
um oh that's what you told me you gave
me this Rick Rossman gave me a tool that
I use in my life all the time which is
if someone says something and I'm not
sure if I understand what they said I
say uh he says can you say it again a
different way yeah and then say it a
different way and then hey got it
because sometimes like people say things
differently sometimes when someone's
like I don't think I understood that say
it differently could you yeah could you
say it again a different way it's just
like the perfect thing and then I go oh
I was totally off instead of like
proceeding you know especially if it's
something delicate so for me it's like
you know what I'm so sorry I think I
wasn't clear do you mind if I say what I
was meant to say in a different way
because I don't think Atlanta properly
because there's no way we would have
this aftermath had I said it the way
that I
would have I wish I had could you do a
moonwalk with your fingers
[Laughter]
you probably not
no uh that's hard did we get that
yeah that's actually a cute thing to do
uh when things get tense is like have a
little goofy thing yeah things are
getting a little tough real quick did
you know that I could walk with my
fingers
but what I will say just gentle reminder
we know that where this started was us
doing an improv you're hung up on where
it started it started it started if I
could do it differently let's not talk
about where it started but I'm talking
the global version but we were playing
stupid people in an improv game I wasn't
your own words I always play everything
to the top of my intelligence I was
playing a girl that was like what are
you doing and why are you doing that I
said why did you look over there such a
cliche I'm just saying for such a good
writer why don't you play a woman with a
little more confidence that
the
net eternity
's improvising but we spent 45 minutes
talking about other stuff as well oh
yeah sure
this is all bonus uh patreon content I
hate when people do that no fucking
right I'm joking I don't do patreon
Christopher no had me on his podcast
sorry I hate that that's fine I hate
being that person correct it I don't
know names I don't know last names okay
so Stefano de Stefano I think yeah
not gonna work here anymore that's for
sure so you know that reference from
Office Space he doesn't know how to
pronagasa not uh not uh not gonna work
here anymore that's for sure
podcast in the back half was it got wild
and was fun but he likes to keep his
podcasts an hour I was never told that
and he put out the hour and then the
other half was on patreon and it's like
do that make your money do your thing
but tell me first because I'm giving the
goods interesting yeah I wouldn't uh
this one you could put the back on
patreon but like yeah yeah tell me if
you're gonna are you giving me a cut
interesting that's an interesting
question huh because yeah I guess but
also no one's getting paid to do
podcasts that aren't you don't need to
pay me but I came all the way over here
to be public with this with these Bits
And if now less people are gonna see it
so you could make some money off it by
the way it is it's like it's not that
big of a deal that just came into my
mind like whatever it is a question it
made me like when you said that it
didn't make me like fuck that
um
yeah I pay people to do my patreon
episodes and if you want to see some of
them head on over to patreon.com take
your shoes off Kevin another water
[Laughter]
all right elephants we love you
[Music]